determina si la relación dada por el
siguiente conjunto de parejas ordenadas
es una función muy bien como pequeño
recordatorio vamos a platicar de que era
una relación y que necesitamos pedirle a
una relación para que sea función vamos
a empezar con relación una relación es
algo que relaciona elementos entre dos
conjuntos uno que voy a poner por acá
así como una nube que se llama el
dominio dominio
y otro que voy a poner aquí a la derecha
que también va a ser como una nube
que se llama el rango
el rango entonces una relación hace más
o menos lo siguiente tomamos un elemento
del dominio déjame poner por acá un
elemento digamos que es el 1 y a éste le
asignamos algún elemento del rango
entonces le asignamos digamos este de
acá que aquí va a ser el 2 vale entonces
la relación está relacionando este 1 con
este 2 bueno vamos a poner otro más
supongamos que aquí hay un 2 entonces
este 2 imaginemos que también está
relacionado con el 2 de acá ahí no hay
problema vale entonces o sea podemos
tener que que en las relaciones dos
elementos están relacionados con uno
mismo y pues también podríamos tener un
tercer elemento que digamos que se va al
-7 o sea que está relacionado con el
menos 7 va ok entonces éste va a pagar
el 3 y el menos 7 están relacionados
entonces si quisiera pasar está
relacionada simbolitos diría lo
siguiente diría voy a poner que unas
llaves que tenemos la pareja 12 primero
va el número del dominio luego el del
rango que tenemos la pareja 22 22 y que
tenemos la pareja 3 - 7 la pareja 3 coma
menos 7 vale ok ya una relación que es
así que a cada uno de los elementos del
dominio le podemos asignar únicamente un
elemento del rango a una relación que
cumpla eso le llamamos una función
entonces una función la podemos pensar
como como pues una caja
voy a poner aquí como una caja
que a través de esta caja podemos tomar
un elemento en el dominio meterlo a la
caja
y esa caja nos va a dar en respuesta un
único elemento del rango ba entonces un
elemento del dominio se manda a un único
elemento del rango esta es una relación
pero también es una función déjame hacer
un dibujo de algo que sea una relación
pero no sea una función para que veas
cuál es el problema entonces una vez más
por aquí voy a dibujar una nubecita esto
de las nubes y estás es más que nada
para indicar que estoy marcando solo
algunos elementos entonces este va a ser
el dominio acá voy a poner el rango
sin rango ok y entonces aquí voy a poner
digamos que tengo el 1 y el 1 lo voy a
mandar al 2
entonces el 1 al 2
voy a poner otro más digamos el 2 vamos
a pensar que el 2 se va pues no sé
digamos al 3 por decir algo
entonces 2 y 3 están relacionados 1 y 2
están relacionados pero vamos a pensar
que el 1 también se va al 4 vale
entonces el 1 también se va al 4 como
pondría esto con llavecitas pues pondría
que la relación está dada por la pareja
bueno 4 y 2 323 entonces estoy aquí es
una relación perfectamente válida está
relacionando algunos elementos de acá
con algunos elementos de acá sin embargo
esta relación no es una función porque
qué pasa con el 1
qué pasa si intentamos determinar el
elemento que está asignado al 1 pues no
hay solo 1 verdad hay 2 está el 2 y el 4
entonces si alguien me pregunta cuál es
el elemento que está relacionado con el
1 no le puedo responder y por lo tanto
esto de acá no sería una función le voy
a poner que no es función función vale
entonces el problema es que un elemento
del dominio esté relacionado con más de
un elemento del rango ok entonces con
esto en mente vamos al problema vamos a
pasarnos para acá para ver qué sucede
entonces déjame apuntar el dominio le
voy a poner aquí dominio
vamos a ver cuál sería el dominio de
esta relación va entonces el dominio el
dominio sería tenemos que ver las
primeras entradas de cada una de las
parejas entonces aquí lo voy a poner con
llave citas podría poner mi nube pero
vamos a acostumbrarnos a la anotación de
llave citas entonces tenemos que poner
este menos tres menos tres luego tenemos
que poner este menos 2 - 2
hay que poner este 0 0 este menos 2 pero
el menos 2 ya está así que ya no lo
pongo entonces este menos 2 ya aparece
aquí y finalmente tengo que poner un 3
menos 3 menos 20 y 3 sería el dominio
vamos con el rango entonces el rango
un color azul hito el rango
el rango cuál sería cuál es el conjunto
de valores que están en las entradas de
la derecha pues a ver está el 2 el 2 el
entre el 4 y el 5 5 el 6 y el 8 y el 8
muy bien entonces imagínate que esto de
acá es la nubecita de la derecha estoy
acá es la nube si estás de la izquierda
vamos a dibujar las asociaciones déjame
agarrar el color amarillo entonces con
amarillo voy a marcar esta dice el menos
3 lo mandó al 2 el menos 3 lo mandó al 2
muy bien ahora color naranja dice el
menos 2 lo mandó al 4 - 2 lo mandó al 4
ok el 0 lo mandó al 50 lo mandó al 50 va
para cinco muy bien ahora dice el menos
2 se va al 6
voy a ponerlo de este color dice el -2
se va al 6 ojo aquí ya estamos asignando
todos valores entonces como que suena
que hay problemas verdad como que esto
ya no va a ser una función nada más
déjame marcar el último y ahorita
regresamos a eso entonces el 3 se va al
8 el 3 se va al 8 entonces justo como te
comentaba el menos 2 va a tener
problemas el menos 3 no el menos 13 si
alguien me pregunta a dónde va el menos
3 yo le puedo decir totalmente seguro
que el menos 3 va al 2 entonces ahí no
hay problema pero qué pasa si alguien me
pregunta a dónde se va el -2 a dónde
está asignado oa dónde está mapeado
algunos lo dicen así pues el menos 2
tiene flechita para el 4 y tiene
flechita para el 6 entonces pasa algo
similar a esto y por lo tanto la
relación no es una función no es una
función porque no sabemos a dónde se va
el -2 sin ambigüedades entonces dejarlo
escribo por acá voy a escribir en color
amarillo la relación
la relación
no es función no es función vale bueno
le voy a dejar hasta aquí nos vemos
hasta la próxima